yes batista of course is also the band
leader for the late show with stephen
colbert here on cbs now we can call him
an oscar winner grammy winner mr
everything he joins us now for his first
broadcast tv interview since music's
biggest nights congratulations
congratulations yeah round of applause
for you mr bethesda
but i do think that you look stunned i
really want to and number one lenny
kravitz is announcing it let's just
start with how about that how about that
you really did look
stunned yeah what are you feeling in
that moment were you you heard your name
i i heard we
and then everybody erupted into this
applause and i was just like wow okay
this is happening it was surreal because
my grandfather's day he's almost 90
years old my nephews are there my mom
and dad my sister i have so many people
in my family there and we were focused
on the performance yeah and that had
just happened maybe like 20 minutes
prior and we had worked on this
performance
from wednesday until that sunday
and as as he saw in the performance i
just gave everything everything i was in
this kind of uh sedated
state where i was like okay we have one
more award left i'm i'm just gonna have
a good time now yeah and then they said
i'm still i basically was like oh i'm
still on
so they said but he said we are and i
said oh i gotta get back to the vibe
okay
so
it was it was a a moment of of
great joy as well
i mean man people were so loud there was
just and all the other artists there was
so much support and love in there that
you know
it it really is a lot to process yeah we
were talking about you yesterday of
course on the show and you really do
john honest to god you are walking joy
to me your whole energy your personified
yes it's just joyous so we were so happy
for you
to collect your thoughts on that stage
that night
it was really my my my thoughts
extemporaneously i just
i didn't
know what else to say other than to say
what happened what i said what was on my
heart in that moment and and i think
there's a lot of people
who are out there even just a day later
who are writing in to me and and telling
me that those words yes not just the
fact that you know we made this album
and all the things that went into this
album but
the words on that night were a
culmination of so many people's
experiences so many artists out there
who are putting it out there and being
rejected time and time again being
himself and and just to see
you can be yourself and you can win we
were also very excited to hear on sunday
and we learned with the rest of the
country that you were married in
february to your longtime partner seleka
jawad yes yes congratulations thank you
how does that feel
i i love it i'm i'm waiting for the
opportunity for us to have a um a
vacation
and um a honeymoon and do do
do that because we're in a bit of a
different
it's an unusual scenario
for for newlyweds you know she's been
sick yeah and um she's really battling
not just sick she's battling yes
yeah had a bone marrow transplant that's
right that's right in um in february she
had a bone marrow transplant and you
know every day
we're waiting
to to gauge how the body's responding to
that
so
you know every day is
something that we take as a precious
gift yeah that sunday morning piece i
have to say if you haven't seen it
audience jim axelrod's piece i emailed
him this morning
to hold the it's it's very very powerful
i was moved to tears john honestly we
were watching it this morning
to hold two things at the same time the
same time you get all these nominations
for your grammy
she is also getting the news that she
needs to go through to go through this
battle to hold those two conflicting
emotions at the same time it reminds me
of the title of her best-selling memoir
about struggling with illness it's
called between two kingdoms it's a
metaphor the kingdom of health and the
kingdom of sickness yes you guys have
been living there oh my goodness it's
been
one of the most trying times of both our
lives and our families you know it's one
of those things that you think about
winning a grammy album of the year
you know you think about dreams you
dream of that and then you also
dream of of finding a love of your life
getting married but you don't imagine
those things with this in the middle of
it this this this battle and i guess for
for us
as crazy as it may sound we've found the
blessing in that mm-hmm because it puts
gives you a perspective
on both things
the highs and lows it gives you great
perspective on both things that are
happening and how to kind of
find the lesson in the lows
and to appreciate the highs and and see
them for what they are as well yeah john
i'm glad you said that and you know i
want to move along to the awards of
course and the music and everything that
you're doing but when you speak it's
extremely powerful and i'm thank i'm
thankful for an individual that can talk
from the heart like you do
i imagine there's viewers at home that
are dealing with somebody who may be
sick they hear words like leukemia and
they grapple with their own mortality or
the ones that they love
what advice would you give them because
you are
living in the moment in a situation that
can crumble relationships and crumble
the spirit
of those in that relationship
what do you say to somebody who's
watching
that says i identify with what they're
going through
there's a joy
to to living
that's
is still available to us
it's always still available to you no
matter what you're going through i look
at
the folks
even in the ukraine you see
musicians playing on the street yeah
you see people playing there's a
beautiful
child singing in a bomb shelter you see
all of these things that happen in
history throughout time you go back in
time you see people finding ways to
find that joy of living
find that moment of transcendence
it's incredible to me it brings me to
tears just think about the way that
people
and the resilience of people the way
that people find that joy so that's what
i would say
the joy of living is still available to
us
well said and take that listen and when
we think about joy i think about you on
stage stephen colbert he can't help it
he made a crack about your outfits last
night
i see that he wore his more casual
outfit
how do you just i was wondering what you
were going to wear today to be honest
with you how do you decide because
clearly you like color yes how do you
decide what you're going to do in that
moment you have a very unique fashion
sense yes yeah you know i i'm blessed to
have a great team and we like to create
worlds and we think about these pictures
and how they're going to stay there
that's right ever think about these
performances and i still watch
performances from the grammys
years and years later now i mean
performances from before i was born
and
you just want to
figure out what this world all of this
color here john yeah that like that yeah
so what are you thinking there this is a
world that we talked about
for months that we wanted to create a
world of color world of joy shout out to
jamel mcwilliams my creative director
who is really an incredible visionary
and then you have hugo mozier who's
stylist and we
collaborated with dolce gabbana to
create these looks 40 custom looks the
set we were thinking about
what is the joy and
what is the um the world of my
imagination if you could create it
on stage what would that look like the
competition was so tough for album of
the year oh yeah so did that one mean
the most to you i mean i know they're
all very important i get it yes but what
did that one mean the most to you um
definitely definitely meant the most to
to win it just felt so
so beautiful you know my nephew probably
the youngest person ever to get a grammy
for album of the year seven years old
this is seven seven seven years old
feature performance recording but you
know i just feel
feel that people need to break these
categorizations they want to reduce you
they want to say that this is just jazz
it's just new orleans music it's just
and we just wanted to prove to the
performance and then
you know having that performance go the
way that it did and it felt so electric
in the room and so many people
responding to it and just being one of
these kind of moments they do during the
performance i'm curious was there a
moment that you said we got the audience
that lean
yeah check out the audience applause in
in in the room you can hit on the
broadcast it's just people erupted and
you know these are the other performers
that knight have songs that were number
ones and this song a lot of people
probably hadn't even heard until that
moment
and they are responding in real time to
the performance in a way that was just
visceral yeah you could feel the energy
in there
and and for us to then win album of the
year it just shows that music
and the genres and all these ways of
trying to box us into one genre one
thing
that's just not a real reality at all
and so on that subject you're also
composing a symphony yeah are you done
with it is it ready to go it's coming
it's coming
it's coming i have uh these incredible
performances at carnegie hall coming up
april 24th is the first
black all-black symphony orchestra
composer pairing premiere in the history
of carnegie hall wow and then wow may
7th may 7th is the american symphony and
that's
if a symphony orchestra was invented in
the 21st century
what music would they play
who would be in the orchestra
and and and
how would that
how would that look how would that feel
um you know you'd have
i imagine you'd have
native american
traditional musicians next to
electronic musicians next to jazz
musicians next to marching band
musicians and all playing together and
creating this music that's rooted in
this experience of diversity and um
i'm excited to premiere this there's
nothing i've ever heard like this i
can't imagine john bautista people who
are reaching out to you that have
projects and ideas for you
would you work on me with me with this i
have a movie i have a deal does stephen
colbert need to look for a new band
leader
[Laughter]
does he need to take applications well i
do know this yesterday's price ain't
today's price giveaway
that's a fact
thank you so much for blessing
yesterday's relaxing today's friday i
hope you have some time to relax and
enjoy yourself and soak it all in i do
too i love in your piece with jim um jim
axelrod you said there's brightness and
there's darkness that's life strap-on
yeah strap-on i like that that's right
we appreciate you jon bates
congratulations to you and everybody in
your crew bravo